I've been working for, you know,
15 years as a stunt performer on
a variety of sets all over the world.
Majority of the day is
you're fighting and falling.
"Atomic Blonde"...
I am so proud of that movie.
So, we had this stairwell
scene, this fight,
that in the script was,
she shoots two guys.
But, you know, we were talking
to Dave and we were like,
"Hey, you know, what if we
do this epic fight scene?"
We actually went to the
stairwell and we shot it
how we would shoot it on set.
So, we call this a previs, a stunt previs,
and then we have Charlize go in and
shoot the first section until it was good,
sometimes 15 to 20 takes for each section,
because it had to be perfect.
They put me in when it was the -
you know, throwing -
getting thrown down the stairs,
and getting thrown into the wall,
and then back to Charlize's section.
I'm so proud of that sequence.
I think we really accomplished
something incredible.
She's beautiful, but she is tough.
She wants to be good.
She wants to do everything.
And she was there, all the
time, in the gym with us,
and you know, the Tom Cruises
and the Angelina Jolies
and Charlize and Keanu, like,
they're all very athletic
and very talented.
The problem is they can't
do all their own stunts
because of liability,
and, you know, you can't -
just can't do that.
I get excited, but I'm not
nervous, I don't fear the stunt.
And I just go through
the stunt in my mind.
I make sure everything -
all the rigging looks good.
And then you just go,
"Okay, cool, call action."
Like, "I'm ready, let's do this."
So, I probably worked for
10 years without my family
really knowing what I was doing.
Now my mom works in film,
though, so she sees everything.
She once brought me my grenade launcher.
That was pretty hilarious.
Like, "Mom, I need my grenade launcher!"
My story is I was modeling,
and so, all the models
were taking acting classes,
and they were, you know,
being extras on set
to make extra money.
And I saw this girl roll down some stairs,
and shoot some guns,
and beat up some dudes,
and I was like, "I want to do that."
You know, most of my training
was in the park by myself,
running and falling
over and over and over again
until it felt natural.
I have probably fallen thousands of times.
Sometimes I am the only woman in the room.
There's definitely a
lack of female leadership
in our stunt industry.
So, you know, you're falling,
but you're falling in
a skirt all the time.
You know, I go into
the costumes, and I go,
"No skirts. We're going to do pants now."
But I think it's changing,
and I was the first
female stunt coordinator
that Marvel has hired.
As a stunt coordinator, you're
taking on the responsibility
of designing all the
action, the stunt action,
making sure it's as safe as possible,
and then coming up with
some really creative way
to tell the story through action.
The riskiest stunt, I think,
that I've done is in -
we were shooting in Bulgaria,
and I was driving a two-horse
chariot at a full gallop.
I had to jump from the
chariot to the horse
and it was just me in the chariot.
That one got me going like, "Whew, okay."
As soon as they call action,
you just, you have to commit.